Trascrizione: Alessio Politi
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Immaginate un artista
all'apice della sua carriera,
e un collezionista
che più di ogni cosa
desidera avere un suo ritratto.
Siamo negli anni '80,
e vi vorrei raccontare, oggi,
la storia di un'opera avvolta nel mistero.
Un'opera di cui abbiamo perso i colori,
di cui abbiamo perso le misure,
abbiamo perso la storia;
ma non abbiamo perso il titolo.
L'artista di cui vi sto parlando oggi
è Gino De Dominicis,
e aveva già realizzato
all'epoca diverse opere.
Come questa, per esempio:
una performance il cui titolo
era abbastanza autoesplicativo:
"Tentativo di far formare dei quadrati,
invece che dei cerchi,
attorno a un sasso che cade nell'acqua".
Oppure quest'altra opera,
per cui aveva richiesto
un trasportatore ufficiale, una cassa.
Infatti l'opera era molto ingombrante,
era complicatissima da spostare.
si trattava infatti di un cubo.
Il titolo: "Un cubo invisibile".
Il tempo passava,
e il collezionista esigeva la sua opera:
"Gino, voglio avere il mio ritratto!".
E così De Dominicis lo soddisfò,
e presentò questo:
un puntino su uno sfondo monocromatico.
Il collezionista era basito,
come voi oggi.
Non capiva: "Dov'è il mio ritratto?",
"Dove sono?" "Non riesco a ritrovarmi!"
Fu il titolo a risolvere la questione:
"Ritratto di collezionista
visto da dieci chilometri di distanza".
Questa opera di Giorgione è conservata
alla galleria dell'Accademia di Venezia.
È stata realizzata
nel primo decennio del 1500
e non abbiamo dei dubbi sul titolo.
La didascalia è molto chiara,
precisa, rettangolare:
"La Tempesta".
In realtà, questo titolo
non è originario di Giorgione:
infatti vedremo come il titolo
è un concetto moderno,
non è sempre esistito
come noi lo diamo per scontato,
un po' come, forse, "Ti chiami Marco,
Giulia, Claudio, Francesca".
In realtà, questo titolo
deriva da un inventario;
e in particolare, da una descrizione
che ci fa Gabriele Vendramin,
che vede l'opera nella collezione
di Marcantonio Michiel.
Il titolo?
"Paesetto in tela con la tempesta
con la cingana e il soldato,
fu de man de Zorzi de Castelfranco".
Da questa descrizione,
non sembra che sapessero
che cosa fosse il vero soggetto,
infatti è un'opera misteriosa.
Erano passati pochi decenni
dalla realizzazione:
tuttavia la storia tende a semplificare,
e ha fatto sì che il titolo
fosse: "La Tempesta".
Sono qui oggi per parlarvi
dei titoli delle opere d'arte,
e più che altro del "Senza Titolo".
Perché la realtà è che siamo avvolti
dai titoli, siamo soffocati:
i titoli dei film,
i titoli dei quotidiani,
i titoli delle riviste,
i titoli delle canzoni,
i titoli degli album, i titoli dei TED.
Oppure il mio titolo,
che è "Senza Titolo".
Viviamo in un mondo di titoli,
come i nostri stessi nomi;
e in qualche modo
questi titoli ci soffocano.
E per pensarci basta ricordare un incubo,
che ebbe l'artista
del Minimalismo Robert Morris,
che contestava
anche lo stesso Minimalismo.
E una notte si svegliò bruscamente,
e iniziò a riflettere
su quanto le didascalie
non fossero innocenti:
"Sono delle granate di parole,
dei farfugli borbottanti,
che schiacciano l'immaginazione".
Il titolo non è
sempre esistito, come dicevo.
Infatti, in passato,
il committente affidava ad un artista
la realizzazione di un'opera
e questo lo realizzava, la scolpiva,
spesso con l'aiuto
di umanisti o letterati.
Quindi il titolo,
in qualche modo, non esisteva.
Inoltre le opere, molto spesso,
erano "trasparenti",
nel senso che il soggetto
era chiaramente visibile.
Vediamo qui: una "Madonna col Bambino";
"San Pietro e Paolo";
"San Giovanni Battista".
Oppure anche i santi patroni locali,
come "Santa Lucia"
o "San Giorgio e il Drago".
Le opere rimanevano
in un contesto culturale
specifico, riconoscibile,
chiaramente influenzato
dall'ambiente che le circondava:
era raro che queste opere si muovessero.
È la democratizzazione dell'arte:
la nascita delle accademie,
la nascita delle mostre,
lo sviluppo del mercato,
l'alfabetizzazione, la stampa,
che fa sì che le opere abbiano
qualcosa che tutti voi avete oggi:
un passaporto, una carta d'identità.
Una maniera per potersi
spostare nel tempo,
per la trasmissione da padre in figlio,
e nel luogo,
per potersi muovere nello spazio,
per poter attraversare le frontiere.
E così le opere iniziano, piano piano,
ad assumere dei titoli.
Sono una storica dell'arte,
e ho sempre amato
la libertà delle immagini.
E mi sono chiesta come il titolo
potesse influenzare così tanto
la percezione di un'opera:
poi faremo un esperimento insieme.
Ma una volta letto un titolo, è finita!
Non riusciamo più a vedere
ciò che avevamo immaginato prima:
siamo schiacciati, siamo oppressi;
siamo condizionati, semplicemente.
Tuttavia ci sono artisti
che coi titoli hanno giocato molto.
Guardate quest'opera,
del pittore William Turner.
Prendo fiato,
perché il titolo è spaventoso:
"Tempesta di neve. Battello a vapore
al largo della bocca di un porto,
che fa segnali in acque poco profonde
e passa il comando.
L'autore era in questa tempesta,
nella notte che l'Ariel Lasciò Harwich".
È tutto un titolo.
Il livello a cui sono arrivati i titoli,
poi, è stato incredibile.
Duchamp diceva che era
un altro colore della tavolozza,
un elemento fondamentale
e costituente l'opera d'arte.
E ci sono poi artisti,
come per esempio
tanti artisti del Surrealismo,
che hanno giocato molto con i titoli,
come in questo caso: Miró.
Direte "È semplicemente
un'opera astratta!".
Invece si tratta di
"Una donna sulla riva del lago,
resa iridescente
dal passaggio di un cigno".
Oppure quanti di voi,
in quest'altra opera,
riuscirebbero a vedere delle
"Figure nella notte guidate dalle tracce
fosforescenti delle lumache"?
Ma Mirò, poi, ha avuto dei ripensamenti
e ha scritto una lettera
al suo gallerista, Pierre Matisse,
il terzogenito del pittore Henri Matisse.
Scrisse, il 12 ottobre del 1934:
"Caro Pierre, ho pensato molto
alla questione dei titoli
e devo confessare
che non riesco a trovarne nessuno
che non sia arbitrario.
In passato ho dato dei titoli,
ai miei lavori" -
e che titoli, abbiamo visto -
"ma mi sono, sempre, sembrati uno scherzo.
Ti do il permesso di dare dei titoli,
con la condizione che non evochino.
Questo è qualcosa
che voglio evitare completamente:
Composizione, per esempio.
Quei titoli letterati
in maniera surrealista."
I titoli, quindi,
costituiscono un problema
anche per gli artisti.
Devono essere identificate,
le opere d'arte;
ma come, se la parola, i nomi - "Giulio" -
condizionano così tanto
la vostra percezione?
Vi ricorda un Giulio
che avete conosciuto, per esempio.
Quest'opera è del pittore americano,
che lavorò soprattutto in Inghilterra,
James Abbott Mecneill Whistler.
È il 1872, quando presenta quest'opera
alla Royal Academy di Londra.
Il titolo? "Composizione
in grigio e nero numero uno".
Intendeva l'opera
come una composizione cromatica,
non voleva che vedessimo un soggetto.
Viene forzato a dare un titolo,
e a specificare che si tratta
del ritratto della madre di Whistler,
il ritratto della madre dell'artista.
È furioso.
Si chiede perché gli inglesi,
e forse intendeva tutto il pubblico,
non riescono a percepire un'opera
come un'opera d'arte,
e si interessano soprattutto
alla storia - attenzione -
che si suppone un'opera possa raccontare.
Che si suppone un'opera,
un'immagine, possano raccontare.
Ma lasciamo l'Europa, la vecchia Europa,
e andiamo in America, negli Stati Uniti.
Dove negli anni Quaranta,
nei primissimi anni Quaranta,
nasce l'Espressionismo Astratto.
Quest'opera è di Jackson Pollock:
il titolo, "Senza titolo".
Attenzione, non è
che non ha dato il titolo:
ha scelto di intitolarla "Senza Titolo".
Obbligato a dare un titolo,
ha scelto "Senza Titolo".
Capite l'impatto, e la forza,
di un gesto così importante,
senza precedenti.
Crea confusione: come indicarlo?
Pensate a una biblioteca
in cui tutti i volumi sono senza titolo.
Come ordinarne uno? Come parlarne?
Come descriverlo? Come citarlo?
Eppure, Pollock ha scelto: "senza titolo".
Ma questa scelta non è stata fortunata,
non è stata apprezzata,
sicuramente, dalla critica.
Infatti, pochi anni dopo
espone quest'opera: "Numero Trenta".
La espone per diversi anni,
dal 1951 al 1952, '53;
e successivamente,
quando viene esposta, nel 1955,
alla Galleria Sidney Janis
il titolo è: "Ritmo Autunnale".
Aveva individuato i numeri
come una soluzione per poter
non influenzare lo spettatore;
tuttavia, creavano confusione.
Immaginate il collezionista:
"il numero 30"; "il numero 12".
E così nasce un "Ritmo Autunnale".
Ma sono altri i pittori
che hanno vissuto più in profondità,
anche la durezza e le conseguenze
di un senza titolo.
In particolare la loro storia
si intreccia con questa donna:
"la mecenate dell'arte",
la signora Peggy Guggenheim.
È il 1946 quando invita
Clyfford Still, pittore americano,
a tenere una personale alla sua galleria,
"Art of this Century", a New York.
Organizza la mostra,
ci sono gli inviti e tutto quanto;
e poco prima dell'inaugurazione
lei e André Breton
vanno a visualizzare le opere,
con Styll presente.
Sono tantissime opere,
le apprezzano molto - ma i titoli?
"Ah, no, le opere sono tutte senza titolo"
I due sono furiosi.
Come vendere un'opera d'arte?
Come raccontarla?
Questo "senza titolo" crea confusione!
E così, grazie alle ricerche
anche del professor David Anfam,
siamo riusciti a ricostruire
tutte le opere esposte.
I due hanno obbligato,
vincolato, schiacciato Styll.
L'hanno forzato a mettere dei titoli
alle opere d'arte.
E sono dei titoli pressanti:
"Elegia", "Premonizione", "Autoritratto",
"Gatto Siamese e Figlie".
Sono dei titoli molto impattanti.
Vogliamo fare un esperimento?
Guardate quest'opera,
esposta in questa mostra,
originariamente senza titolo.
Una composizione,
o come qualsiasi cosa
voi vorreste che quest'opera sia.
E invece no,
perché Peggy Guggenheim e André Breton
hanno dato questo titolo:
"Lo Spettro e il Pappagallo".
Non so quanti di voi, ora,
riuscirebbero a vedere
qualcosa di diverso, sulla sinistra:
un pappagallo chiaramente, nella forma.
E se rivedrete quest'opera,
ci vedrete sempre un pappagallo:
non riuscirete a vedere nient'altro.
Mark Rothko inizia a dare dei titoli
abbastanza riconoscibili,
sicuramente tradizionali.
Troviamo infatti: "Figura"; "Donna";
"Paesaggio"; "Scena metropolitana"
e così via.
Sono titoli riconoscibili:
permettono di acquisire delle opere,
di parlarne, di citarle,
permettono all'artista di avere
delle recensioni importanti.
È dal 1946 che lui si spinge
verso l'astrazione:
contesterà anche il termine, "astrazione".
Tuttavia, è come se queste figure
si espandessero
su dei piani monocromatici,
si dissolvessero piano piano.
E seguono le parole.
E così anche Mark Rothko:
anche lui, negli anni Quaranta,
inizia a non dare i titoli
alle opere d'arte: "Senza Titolo".
Tuttavia, come nel caso di Pollock,
è costretto a cercare
di individuare queste opere,
e quindi utilizza dei numeri.
Però vince su tutti Rothko, perché?
Perché cambia i numeri continuamente:
a una stessa opera dà diversi numeri,
via via che la espone.
È una confusione totale,
non si capisce più niente.
La ricostruzione del catalogo di Rothko
è stata infatti complicatissima,
perché le opere cambiavano il titolo
via via che erano esposte.
Cambiava anche
l'orientamento delle stesse.
Immaginate la confusione, e la bellezza,
di un gesto del genere,
che contesta ciò che abbiamo
sempre creduto.
Cioè che con l'erudizione, con lo studio,
un giorno saremmo riusciti
a avvicinarci alle opere d'arte.
Invece è proprio il contrario:
è una danza, un movimento,
un corteggiamento,
una dedica d'amore, una dedizione.
Infatti questo è l'unico modo
per poter fare esperienza
delle opere d'arte,
poterle abbracciare in qualche modo
e non catalogare e definire precisamente.
Tuttavia, anche questi numeri
creano moltissima confusione.
E così, quando anche lui inizia
a lavorare con un gallerista,
iniziano i titoli, i colori come i titoli.
Ecco che vediamo
"Bianco e Rosso su Giallo".
Rothko è furioso,
perché i titoli sembrano diventati colori,
sembrano diventati il soggetto;
ma non è assolutamente così.
Infatti scriverà precisamente
che "non sono i colori
il soggetto dell'opera".
Non è neanche una composizione astratta:
semplicemente non è, o è,
ciò che ciascuno di voi, oggi,
vuole vedere in quest'opera.
Ci sono serviti centinaia
di migliaia di titoli
perché potessimo arrivare
al "Senza Titolo".
Immaginate la potenza
di un gesto del genere, senza precedenti.
Addirittura Styll, il pittore
di cui vi ho parlato prima,
cancellerà retroattivamente
tutti i suoi titoli.
E inventerà un numero
progressivo di inventario
per poterli citare, per poterne parlare.
Un'operazione che nessuno
aveva mai fatto prima.
Ma se ancora non vi ho convinto
dell'importanza del senza titolo,
di sottrarci, invece
che riempirci di parole,
allora pensiamo a Ulisse.
Che quando riuscì ad accecare Polifemo,
poi disse di chiamarsi "Nessuno".
E così, quando gli altri ciclopi
lo soccorsero, dissero:
"Ma chi ti ha accecato?
Chi dobbiamo cercare?"
E lui rispose: "Nessuno". Senza titolo.
Solo così ebbe salva la vita,
perché non lo riuscirono a trovare.
E se ancora non vi ho convinto,
guardate quest'opera
dell'artista Carlo Benvenuto:
uno specchio, che ha invitato a guardarci
e per una volta a sottrarci,
a non chiamarci,
a fare un passo indietro,
a guardare senza esprimere un'opinione.
Semplicemente il sentire.
Ma se questo è un gesto troppo radicale,
perché ciascuno di noi
poi ha un nome, ha un'economia,
si deve muovere, si deve spostare,
deve avere una vita,
dobbiamo riconoscerci in qualche modo.
Allora vi inviterei a tornare
alla "Tempesta" di Giorgione.
E in realtà, è una fotografia
di un artista contemporaneo;
e non l'ha chiamata "Tempesta",
non l'ha chiamata "Senza Titolo".
Ma ha semplicemente deciso
di [chiamarla] "Not yet titled".
Grazie.
(Applausi)